Chameleons' tongues are fast and long--
extending twice their body length in a
fraction of a second.
To find out just
how fast, researchers used high-speed
cameras to film different species of
chamaleon
as they a targeted a suspended cricket.
They found that smaller species had
faster tongues.
The one-centimeter long R. spinosus
can catapult its tongue towards prey
at over 2,500 meters per second.
Faster than any reptile, bird, or mammal.
This incredible acceleration is powered by
14 kilowatts per kilogram of muscle-
-the highest muscle power output of any
terrestrial vertebrate.
Smaller chamaleons need to eat more food each day to survive
and so have proportionally larger tongues
for their body size.
This allows them to propel their tongues at accelerations of up to 264 g--
Too fast for even the nimblest cricket to
outrun.